- Now, Thanksgiving is
right around the corner,
it's almost here, and it's such
a great time of year, right?
A time to hang out with people you love,
you dig way into too much food.
You really just kick back.
No pressure, you don't have
to give gifts or anything.
I'm very excited about
this holiday season.
My whole family is gonna
be on the Turkey float,
the first float, for the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day parade.
(audience applauding)
The whole Lopez fam bam.
We're gonna be bundled up like that,
and I'm also gonna be hosting
part of NBC's live coverage
of Christmas in Rockefeller
Center on the 30th.
And to really go next level,
I have a brand new movie coming
out on Lifetime this Friday.
(audience cheers)
Which I'm really excited about.
I think you all are gonna really like it.
I get to combine so
many things that I love.
I'm dancing and acting,
there's a little romance,
and of course Christmas time.
So here's a little sneak peek at
"Steppin' Into the Holiday."
- [Billy] You know, maybe this
all happened for a reason.
- When my mom retired,
I took over the studio.
Best decision of my life,
and now we're creating
our own Christmas show.
Should I add you to the lineup?
- That's not me anymore.
♪ Chestnuts roastin' ♪
♪ Champagne toastin' ♪
- At your core, you're
this guy, not that guy.
♪ Children wishin' ♪
♪ Lovers kissin' under mistletoe ♪
- And if that means you are falling
for a woman who doesn't have a publicist,
then fall.
- Oh!
- Little tease right there.
I get fired from my job,
I go back home cause my
mom's been asking me,
and I reconnect with the family,
and through my nephew and
this young lady named Rae,
played by Jana Kramer,
I sort of end up kind of findin' love
and the Christmas spirit again.
You know how those movies goes.
With a little dance
and romance in between,
so hope y'all check it out.
So Kelly always likes to
wrap things up with something
people might be buzzing about,
so thought I'd do the same.
This is what I'm likin'.
(electric guitar riff)
At the beginning of the show,
I told you about my new lifetime
movie, debuting on Friday,
"Steppin' Into the
Holiday," it's very cool.
I play a character named Billy
Hernandez, aka Billy Holiday.
He stars as a host for a show,
kinda like "Dancing with the
Stars", but in the movie,
he gets fired, replaced by his ex,
and things take many turns from there.
It's got romance, it's got comedy,
and I love working and dancing
with my co-star, Jana Kramer.
(festive music)
(audience applauding)
We have Jana dialed in now.
Thank you so much for
taking the time to call in.
I know this, but would you
mind telling everyone else
about your character in the movie?
- Yeah, so Rae is a dance instructor.
She used to tour for Katy Perry,
and livin' out of a
suitcase wasn't her thing.
So she went home and that's
where she found her maximum joy,
by teaching kids and
being in her hometown.
- Nice, maximum joy,
one of my favorite expressions from there.
What about personally,
what plans do you have
for the holidays, other
than watching the movie?
- (laughs) I'm definitely
gonna watch the movie,
and then, you know I'm
gonna be honest with you,
this year I was, I have dreaded
this year more than anything
since my divorce, because
this was gonna be the year
that I didn't have my
kids Christmas morning.
But I've never looked forward
to a day more now than ever.
I now am gonna get my kids
on Christmas day at noon,
and Santa is actually come the next day,
so we're gonna celebrate
Christmas the next day
so I don't miss out on, you know,
their little feet pitter-pattering
coming down and seeing
the presents from Santa.
So I'm excited to create
our own memory this year,
and I'm really lookin' forward to that.
- Oh, that's awesome.
I'm so glad that worked out right there.
Thank you so much, Jana.
I'm liking your post
right now. (kiss sound)
That's awesome.
"Steppin' Into the Holiday"
premieres this Friday night
on Lifetime, hope you
check it out and enjoy.
Alright, now.
We've hit the point where
Kelly usually gives the guest
a thousand dollars,
courtesy of the shows
season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
but I think it'd be, it'd
show way too much favoritism
if I give it to Jana, right?
So today, the money's going
to someone in the audience.
(audience cheers)
So if everyone can
please get up real quick,
and look under their chairs,
because someone has a check
taped under their chair,
and is gonna come up
with a thousand bucks.
(Mario cheers)
(audience cheers)
Congratulations, what's your name?
- Kaylee.
Hi Kaylee. Congrats!
- Thank you! Thank you so much!
- What do you,
what do you plan to do with the money?
- I'm going to Bahrain next year,
gonna travel with my husband.
- There you go.
- [Kaylee] Yeah!
- Spend it on the vacation, good for you.
Congrats and happy holidays to you.
Nice!
- Thank you!
And a big thanks to all
our guests this hour,
Jonathan Majors, Christina
Jackson, who were in a lasso,
Angelica Ortega, the P.S. 14
choir, Natalie Pascarella,
and all our friends over at NBC4 New York,
Alex Aster, and Lawrence Zarian.
As Kelly says, have a great
day and if it's not, change it.